formalmente colombia y venezuela vuelven
a tener relaciones diplomáticas
armando benedetti designado por el
gobierno colombiano como embajador en el
país vecino entregó el lunes sus
credenciales al presidente venezolano
nicolás maduro
a esta hora no reciben el palacio de
miraflores el presidente nicolás maduro
a quien presentó cartas credenciales
como embajador de colombia en venezuela
hablamos sobre la urgencia de
restablecer los lazos de amistad que
nunca se debieron romper
maduro recibió a benedetti en una
exclusiva ceremonia ante la prensa sin
embargo la primera charla entre ambos se
llevó a cabo a puerta cerrada
encuentro ameno y fraterno con armando
benedetti el nuevo embajador de nuestra
hermana colombia es el inicio de una
etapa de relaciones diplomáticas de
hermandad paz y respeto un abrazo al
pueblo colombiano ambos países comparten
más de 2.200 kilómetros de frontera y se
espera que el restablecimiento de las
relaciones fomente el comercio bilateral
golpeado por la ruptura diplomática en
2019 hay ciertos sectores en las
poblaciones de la frontera colombiana
que requieren restablecer relaciones
comerciales con venezuela muy bien que
sus principales socios comerciales se
encontraban al otro lado de la frontera
se prevé que la nueva aproximación entre
gobiernos también propicie diálogos
sobre la seguridad fronteriza y la
migración venezolana hacia colombia
que se convirtió en el principal
receptor del éxodo venezolano en la
región según cifras de la oficina de
migración colombia en la nación hay
actualmente más de 24 millones de
ciudadanos venezolanos de los cuales 295
mil se encuentran en situación irregular